One of the highlights of going to a natural
history museum is seeing the ancient, the
extinct, the giant -- animals like dinosaurs
are huge attractions, but the thing is…
what you can see isn’t entirely accurate…
the color’s all wrong.
Some of the first dinosaur fossils were discovered
in the 17th century.
The discoverer thought it was part of a giant
human!
It wasn’t for nearly two centuries that
scientists would realize these bones belonged
not to giants, dragons or pre-flood Biblical
creatures, but to multi-million-year-old dinosaurs.
Immediately, scientists started trying to
gather and arrange bones and fragments into
shapes and species -- many of which they (very
famously) got wrong.
Putting bones together, and knowing what a
dinosaur looks like is a big leap.
And that’s where PaleoArt comes in!
Imagine for a second you have never seen a
living human, no one has.
But someone found a fossilized skeleton.
You don’t know much about this animal, or
what it looked like on the outside.
What does its skin look like, does it have
scales?
Fur?
Feathers?
What color would the skin be?
Would it be camouflaged?
Someone who looks into this, would be a PaleoArtist.
These artists recreate extinct animals and
plants, and they’re they ones who decided
what color dinosaur skin actually is.
Because tbh, no one knows.
In the 19th century, paleoartists took dinosaur
bones; and they used contemporary giants like
elephants and rhinos as well as reptiles to
inspire their idea of what animals would have
that skeleton.
This is how we got massive, tail-dragging
animals plodding hither and thither.
Not accurate.
Over time, scientists debated the finer points
of these animals.
Like, whether the head was held up above the
body -- like a giraffe, or at body level.
How would they pump blood?
How would these bones move if they had muscles…
and the drawings evolved...
By the 1960s and 70s, dinosaurs had trimmed
up, they were looking lighter and fitter -- and
less grey!
More colorful!
But the skin…
THE SKIN.
We’ve found fossilized skin, and it can
tell us the texture, look, and feel of a dinosaur,
but not color.
Fossilization turns dino hyde to stone -- meaning
no melanin, no melanosomes, no color.
At least, not that we can see…
In 2013 a Canadian scanning company took a
textured bit of skin and bounced infrared
wavelengths off of it hoping to reveal the
fossilized melanosomes -- the bits of skin
that hold its color.
They based this on earlier studies that tried
to see if fossilized melanosome shapes could
show us what color they were.
People really want to know this y’all.
Aaaaand, they’re still researching…
They’ve used this method successfully with
well-preserved feathers, which dinosaurs were
definitely covered in.
And FEATHERS could have had numerous colors,
just like the birds dinosaurs evolved into.
But feathers aren’t skin color.
Though it’s maddening -- scientists are
still in the dark on this.
The “most accurate depiction” of a dinosaur
(as it was billed) makes the tiny Psittacosaurus
look cute, and… brown -- which they found
by lasers scanning the melanosomes in the
skin!
But the connection is debated.
And, as long as we’re copying birds, coloring
is often sex specific.
Females are brown, but males are flashy.
That said the shading camouflage makes this
one of the most accurate dinosaur depictions
ever!
For now.
Ultimately, and for much of our depictive
history of these animals, we’ve sort of
been… ‘winging it’ using data that’s
available at the time!
But everything may change soon.
In May 2017, a beautifully preserved fossilized
nodosaur was revealed… found in a Canadian
mine!
It was basically mummified!
They scanned the skin and found the presence
of reddish pigments!
RED.
ISH!
Aaand that’s it so far.
We can’t get pics.
They’re exclusive!
But, I’m sure you can find them.
This dinosaur is gorgeous, we got the hook
up on pics Royal Tyrrell Museum in Canada.
If you notice, still no color.
It just looks like stone.
But, they scanned the skin and found the presence
of reddish pigments!
RED.
ISH!
It’s not a much, but a start!
In the end, the dinosaurs in your imagination
was seeded by the imagination of paleoartists.
Their work is what created dinosaurs in movies,
museums and theme parks.
They fill in the skin on top of the skeletons,
creating this rich tapestry of ancient life…
and for now, a fictional one…
Thanks to HelloFresh for sponsoring this episode.
HelloFresh
is the meal kit delivery service that makes
cooking more fun so you can focus on the whole
experience, not just the final plate.
Meals are less than $10 each and they now
offer light, spring meals, and have just introduced
breakfast options!
For $30 off your first week of deliveries,
visit hellofresh.com and enter <SEEKER30>
when you subscribe!